[Musique]
véritable légende du jazz montréalais
bictogo fait partie de l'âme de la ville
il ya juste ça y est je savais qu
fourgon qui joue à deux pianos cabinet
caisse
fils de parents hongrois dick vogondy a
appris le piano par lui même à l'âge de
5 ans avant de devenir chef d'orchestre
mon papa m'aime un certain baguette et
j'ai dirigé la radio j'ai vraiment la
casse
alors qu'istres qu'il fonde en 1968 le
jazz big band permet à ce style de jazz
de renaître au québec
il va composer et orchestré plus de 2000
pièces entre autres pour radio canada où
il a été directeur musical pour
plusieurs émissions
on lui doit aussi la musique des
cérémonies de l'expo 67 et des jeux
olympiques de montréal de 1976 il est
fait tellement pour muriel suit les
musiciens ici dans la province puis
j'étais en vie et jouer avec lui
j'aimerais qu'on se rappelle que cet
homme n'a vraiment fait connaître le
jazz à des gens qui l'auraient pas connu
au québec
le nom de ce rebelle du jazz apparaît
sur une soixantaine d'albums dont le
célèbre offenbach confusion il y avait
des moments où avec était très difficile
musicalement parlant parce que il n'y
aura ni nous voyaient comme des rockers
qui connaissait trop cinq ans puis s'en
servait juste deux reconnus à
l'international des gorgones a donné
près de dix mille concerts
en 70 ans de carrière il a participé à
34 festival de jazz de montréal
on est chanceux d'avoir eu avec tout ce
talent et ma foi un cliché qui veut que
quand un musicien jazz
paris s'en va rejoindre duke ellington
anciennes douves herrington ça s'adonne
que c'était la grande idole avec google
et j'espère que ça le rend compte avec
le doute à ce moment ci est déjà
commencée
avec google est décédée ici dans sa
demeure à montréal
il était aux côtés de son piano un
steinway fidèle compagnon sur lequel il
jouait depuis l'âge de 16 ans ici louis
fait depuis mai radio canada montréal
[Musique]